I use a percolator because that's what we use in Italy and somebody told me that it burns the coffee
because the water's boiling. Is that carcinogenic?
Which one of your exes would you like to go back and sleep with?
Probably my
First proper boyfriend from when I was about 16, 17
Because I mean we didn't know anything then. We were really young and I'm just a lot better at sex now
and...
I think he probably would be too, and I wonder if that would have changed anything. Would you keep him as a 16 year old?
(laughter)
Which colleague or professional contact
would you like to apologize to? Do you remember when I had that
secretary job after uni? I just couldn't handle getting all of these
invoices and like contracts my desk cuz I just didn't know what to do with them um
and eventually it just really started to stress me out, so I just used to shred everything.
What? You didn't. That's really bad. What?
I just.. I just.. Did you get found out?
No. Because I I left the job after three months and also I actually
and this is... I also emailed everybody on the mailing list saying: "I'm only here for the money-
I'm going down to book the tickets to Vietnam now", but I meant to send it to my cousin
But I sent it to every professional contact. Yeah, no I do feel bad for that actually
because it was a family friend who got me the job. I think should have apologized way sooner actually.
(laughter)
Who is the most unlikely or unusual person you've masturbated to? -oh god
It's probably yeah a
teacher I don't if I can even remember her name
I think you know..
Mrs. Warnock
Just you know when I was still finding finding my feet masturbation-wise
In what way do you think you might be described as bad in bed by an uncharitable person? The fun never stops.
No I'm joking. My mind tends to wander.
Might start thinking about work..
Work?
Yeah...
Has someone called you out for that? Yes many times.
What did you just pause and went and answered an email? Well I cuz if I have a thought?
then I need to attend to it immediately so
I'll be like yeah, so I just need to send this email send this text or take this call
No. That's terrible.
So yeah
How long are you having sex for that you can take time off in the middle?
Yeah, well this does say uncharitable
so yes this going on for awhile. -And it's good to know that I'm I can call you at any time and
And what about you does your partner not understand?
Nothing! You understand me completely.
But I
No something that's come up recently I do feel that yeah when I'm flirting I am known to be quite a flirty person
And obviously I've got a little male friends, and I think sometimes you ah you get really possessive
Really possessive
Sorry I mean.. but but you know and I think it's important for my sense of
autonomy, my sense of potency to, you know feel desired by
More people than just you
Yeah, I think that's.. I do find it uhh I don't really have
lots of female friends, maybe that's it and I just like I
guess just find it weird to know where the line is
I'd like if you flirted more. I mean not with... -You can flirt with me -No -Yeah should I flirt with you?
But would make me feel like you are actually desirable.
At the School of Life we believe in developing emotional intelligence
To that end we've also created a whole range of products to support that growth
Find out more at the link on the screen now